hey folks today is going to be savage we
are launching a new YouTube channel I'm
getting together with two of my friends
Connor shorten and Jana Kilcher and
we're launching this channel and it's
gonna be called machine learning Street
talk my name is Connor Jordan I'm
working on my PhD in computer science at
Florida Atlantic University with a focus
on machine learning I'm making machine
learning research summary videos in the
occasional coding tutorial on Henry AI
Labs
I'm also chatting with fellow machine
learning youtubers Jana Kilcher and Tim
scarf on machine learning Street Talk
machine learning research moves
incredibly fast and I personally
appreciate it when there is a video out
it can help me get an idea of the paper
before I try to read it hopefully you'll
find these videos useful for educating
yourself on what's really going on in
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
[Music]
hi I'm Yannick I'm a guy on the internet
with opinions most of them questionable
I'm a PhD student by day at night
I run a YouTube channel on my channel I
try to analyze and explain the best
greatest and latest research papers if
you like the conversation today head
over to my channel and subscribe and
you'll get much much more enjoy
now I almost don't need to explain what
machine learning Street talk is the
clues of the name right every week we're
going to get together and we are going
to talk about the latest and greatest
and machine learning research and also
we're going to invite several experts
from industry and academia to help us do
this now a little bit about me I've got
a PhD in machine learning I was a
principal machine learning engineer at
Microsoft for the last three years and
now I'm the chief AI Architect at BP
I've been following Conor for just over
a year now he launched his Henry AI labs
YouTube channel and the guy is a machine
I can't believe the pace that he manages
to push content out because I always had
the mindset of looking at you know quite
seminal papers and some of the you know
big contributions but somehow Connor
manages to stay on the very very cutting
edge and just maintain that velocity so
it's incredible I've been in aware of
Yannick for about probably 12 to 18
months as well and when I was
interviewing for the big team I needed
to learn all about how transformer
models worked and there was a dearth of
information out there because no one
really seemed to understand it to be
honest and Yannick has this incredible
style of explaining things on on his
YouTube channel he goes through the
paper methodically and he explains
things in a way that anyone can
understand that it's a real talent to be
honest and someone always said to me
once that you know in order to explain
something simply you have to understand
it very very well
and and I think yeah Anika's is a great
testament to that so for the last year
or so one my own YouTube channel the
machine learning dojo I've been running
a series called paper review calls which
is a way to talk about the latest and
greatest in machine learning research
and I had several of the primary authors
come and talk about their research and I
suppose I kind of see this channel as a
continuation of that series so today's
call we're going to talk about ubers
recent paper
the enhanced poet open-ended
reinforcement learning through unbounded
invention of learning challenges and
their solutions by Wang Tao now this
paper it introduces a new paradigm of
learning which is kind of called AI
generating algorithms or open-endedness
and open-endedness is the the class of
algorithms that generates problems and
solutions of increasing diversity and
complexity and there's a bit of a
parallel here with curriculum learning
because the thing is with curriculum
learning is that complex tasks become
tractable if they are the last
stepping-stone in a sequence of learning
tasks and in in this paper it describes
a methodology for creating that
curriculum automatically now this is a
nice narrative point here because
there's a real progression and machine
learning moving away from handcrafted
expert systems originally people used to
have to write code to do things
increasingly as we embrace machine
learning we could rely on algorithms to
kind of create those rules for us and
some of the algorithm still had fixed
objectives they had a fixed domain and
they had handcrafted inductive priors
encoded into the algorithm and what
we're seeing with open endedness is a
real step away from that allowing the
algorithms themselves to generate
challenges and and solutions to that but
you know there's lots of challenges in
this as well so determining the right
stepping stones in the correct order is
notoriously difficult and we need to
encode novel challenges of appropriate
difficulty so that we don't destroy the
gradient of improvement now the concept
of open endedness it draws a lot of
inspiration from evolution and if you
think about it evolution has produced
our own intelligence and the interesting
thing about evolution is it doesn't
converge it just goes on forever with
traditional machine learning algorithms
you would train them and they would
converge whereas open-endedness is
something which could potentially just
go on forever because you could just
keep creating new problems and solutions
and there's no end in sight so the other
thing is with fixed domain machine
learning the algorithms will only ever
be as good as the humans because the
humans come up with the challenges if
you allow these algorithms to generate
their own challenges then effectively
they might find solutions and strategies
which are even better than humans so
there's a real thing here that it's
interesting to be able to solve
challenges that we don't even know
anyway this is exciting times I hope you
enjoy today's session remember to Like
comment and subscribe and hit that
notification belt and we will see you
back next week
so here we are this is the machine
learning Street talk YouTube channel and
today we are here to talk about the poet
well the enhanced poet paper the Year
pared open-ended trailblazer and we have
a whole bunch of folks in the house so
let's do a round of introductions let's
start with you Connor okay my name is
Connor certain I'm working on my PhD in
computer science and making machine
learning to videos that Henry am ops and
Messi hi I'm Matthew I am currently a
research scientist working in computer
vision thank you
you get yep gotcha can you see my video
now by the way yeah I hope that's so I'm
Keith I got my PhD years and years ago
so I used to be smart but not anymore
and now I work at Microsoft as a
principal technology strategist and just
I have an interest in this kind of thing
listen Eric and Yannick I'm Yannick I am
PhD student and I also make videos
explaining trying to explain papers yeah
okay cool so this this poet's paper it's
it's a really exciting new paradigm of
artificial intelligence it's you know
it's our artificial intelligence
generating because I suppose in in the
olden days we would have a fixed domain
and we would train a machine learning
model to do a particular task
here's Dimitri joining hello Dimitri
we've just kicked off can you introduce
yourself
hello so I work at Microsoft I used to
work with team and doing some research
on projects with European clients and
now I'm cloud developer advocate and I'm
looking forward to this call fantastic
so yes that was dr. Sasha coffee in the
house good stuff so yeah yeah anyway why
don't you and kick off the conversation
and so so this is a new type of
algorithm that can generate simultaneous
new problems and solutions continuously
yes so what what always fascinated me in
this work is I first heard about this
kind of work when I attended a tutorial
by Jeff Clun and Kenneth Oh Stanley at a
conference I don't remember which I
think it was ICML and the quote that
struck me most was if you think about
life on Earth and kind of the the vast
diversity that of life that exists this
is just from a single run of an
optimization process it's not like in
machine learning where we optimize and
hyper tune and start again and and so on
this is just a single run of a process
that produced all of this all of this
diversity and complexity a single
open-ended run and that is what I find
extremely cooling and capturing in a way
and this this new paradigm kind of in it
wants to go that way it wants to build
algorithms that run for a long time and
are open-ended and basically means they
want to create agents that live in
worlds but both of them continuously
evolve so the agents get better at kind
of solving the worlds but the worlds
shift as the agents get better and
therefore you get kind of a branching
out and diverse diverse range of agents
and it turns out in this way you can get
much much much more calm
agents for solving the kinds of problems
that you want to solve then if you were
to go classic reinforcement learning
just I wanna do solve this problem so in
the in these poet examples they have
this Walker right they have this to two
feet bipedal Walker and the goal is just
to get to the right as sorry to the
right as far as possible and if you were
just to go about this with RL there's
lots and lots and lots of hurdles that
we don't know yet how to solve but if
you go about this with this evolutionary
way where you create worlds and you
mutate them and the agents continuously
evolve it turns out this problem
suddenly becomes one that is solvable so
there's a bit of a parallel here with
curriculum learning but I suppose the
difference is this is a curriculum which
rather than being handcrafted is one
which is learned continuously and the
good thing about this you know this
thing is that you can solve really
complex tasks but some complex tasks
only become tractable you know if
they're the final stepping stone you
know in a sequence of learning tasks so
it's about having challenges which are
increasingly more difficult and and more
diverse yes so curriculum learning it
refers to kind of the what you said you
want to kind of build up the complexity
of your problem incrementally such that
your agents that are trying to solve the
problem can always profit from the last
step what these people these people make
the argument that this is not enough
often what you need in their
argumentation are these kind of
stepping-stone goal switching things so
the goal switching is a big part of poet
and of this whole line of work is where
if you evolve very different kinds of
environments it might turn out that what
you learn over here in one type of
environment all of a sudden becomes
useful in another type and in such a way
you couldn't have learned it you
couldn't have directly learned that
skill in for example if there's a
huge cliff right you couldn't just make
the cliff bigger and bigger and bigger
and at some point you're gonna fail but
if over here you have some sort of
higher and higher stairs the skill of
transferring these stairs might all of a
sudden be useful in jumping down the
cliff so in this poet paper and the
extended poet they demonstrate very in a
very cool way how these different skills
can be transferred between the agents
and thereby you can overcome challenges
that curriculum learning in the classic
sense cannot interesting sorry no I
agree with you completely a creative
perspective I see it slightly
differently as well though so usually in
evolutionary algorithms and genetic
programming one of the biggest
frustrations is that you know you carry
out mutation a mutation seems to work
but you know when you're kind of like
doing recombination or crossover things
fall apart because it's very hard to
take two pieces together and get them to
fit now I view the the agent and the
environment as being part of one genome
and what's really nice is that you can
split the genome at the point of the
agent and split the jima at the point of
the environment and they still work okay
so I view it slightly as a nice way of
doing recombination because you still
can pull the agent from like one genome
and put them in another and it kind of
works so I completely agree with your
points but I like the I in my mind I
like that view that you basically are
achieving green combinate good
recombination by allowing to kind of
separate the genome into kind of the
agent and the environment well I want to
interject there because why am I getting
an echo sorry let me fix this that rose
you know you're on the case I'm sorry
about that I'm dealing with two systems
anyway if I understood the algorithm
correctly from my point of view there's
there's almost zero recombination that's
happening yes yeah cuz what it's doing
is it's just taking the best you know
it's it's a 0 1 loss function are you
better than you become the new model for
that entire
and that's kind of one of the concerns I
have about this approach is you're gonna
wind up at the end with a list of
several ai's that are that are great at
subsets of environments and yet we still
have no way whatsoever to actually
combine those to cover a very general
you know complete set of environments I
think the idea is presenting is that you
can have an agent that is like super
performer without the environment so
that's what I think this recombination
idea is an interesting way of looking at
it I never thought about it that way
before but like you can't have some
agent that performs super well unless
it's necessarily coupled with the
environment so that's I think that's an
interesting way of looking at it that
well yeah like you can't you had a have
to evolve together and that's what I
think the recombination I do a good way
of looking at it yeah could I ask a
question as well because the paper talks
a lot about goal switching and it also
talks about you know the contrast to
traditional evolutionary algorithms
which can be thought of as blackbox
optimizers and you know the objective is
fixed but in some sense the objective is
fixed here because as I understand it
the objective is to go from the left
hand side to the right hand side as
quickly as possible
so in some sense when you talk about go
switching you're actually talking about
switching to different environments yeah
that's a really good point yeah it's
still optimizing towards a goal but the
kind of point of that kind of guided
evolution is not necessarily to always
go towards the goal it's kind of to
explore the area as much as possible and
that's why they kind of talks about
novelty and this is Ken Stanley's work
has mainly been around novelty for a
very very long time so this is
definitely like the kind of area that
he's very much interested in
so like undirected kind of golus
exploration but it does come to the kind
of you know question of you know if you
had a space which was much much larger
you can't possibly explore everything so
how do you be able to exploit it so I
think the the key part the key cool
things about poet and enhance poet are
fantastic to being able to kind of
achieve these almost seemingly
impossible tasks but at the same time
many other real-world applications where
the dimensionality is so much higher
they would struggle because you'd have
to have like unlimited compute in order
to be able to make them tractable to
just riff on that just for a second Matt
so what what is it in particular about
the poet formulation is it because the
the way that the environments are
generated and parameterised is is
limited yes at this moment I'm there's
there's only so much variety that you
can have within this kind of very
specific environment and if you think
about it the bipedal walkers only got
like we're like four joints etc it's
really it's a very limited environment
so therefore it becomes computationally
tractable in the computation that we
have today now if you took something
that's a little bit more complicated I'm
pretty sure that you'd see that it would
just be impossible to solve within any
kind of realistic time frame so I think
the kind of idea of being able to
explore an area is fantastic
what you'd want to be able to do is to
do it even more sample efficiently to be
able to do it with even less examples to
be able to do it without necessarily
having to sample the environment but to
have some way to be able to say oh
that's that's you know really you know
kind of important to me in the sample
efficiency in my opinion you know I
think what I was saying earlier that
there's no recombination it's this Delta
loss zero one I think we're losing
information there right well if we're
only keeping the very best model for an
environment and totally ignoring like
every other models contribution you know
there's an information loss there and
like I said I got my PhD a long time ago
so I keep when I was watching an X video
I kept thinking how much of what he's
saying could I phrase in the context of
like an old-school contour map where I'm
like yeah I don't want to fall down this
valley so I'm gonna keep the annealing
temperature high so I can jump over it
into a different area and maybe find the
global the global optimum it's over here
it's like this is a genetic algorithm
like to me there was like so little new
actually I'm struggling to see why it's
considered so novel and and I just see
information lost like at every step in
the algorithm so that was my concern
yeah sorry I think the information loss
isn't too bad because you have this
population of the ages and that's why I
think it's so important that this is a
population of Asian not
they're not optimized with say policy
gradients and it's not the same agent
with policy gradients in the same model
rather you're using evolutionary
strategies optimization so I think
that's how you don't lose too much
information if you maintain the
diversity and the controller's of a
agent I'm just saying are these
competing there are these competing you
know processes there is information loss
yes there's a population of agents but
they're a population of specialized
agents agents that become specialized to
their particular environment and only by
happenstance may actually work in
another environment so there's there's
just there's some cross crosstalk and
it'll be interesting to see how it plays
out and or what specific avenues are to
bridge these gaps these information gaps
I think the authors whenever they they
talk about it they always kind of draw
the parallels to to real-life and to
this evolutionary process of real life
and I think you have the same thing
there where you have a niche that's kind
of occupied by a species but then maybe
it slightly changes right and then all
of a sudden another species is better
and just completely wipes out the first
species right it's not the most
efficient like you could think of let's
take the best of both species but that's
not what happens usually what happens is
that this species comes in dominates and
wipes out this other whole entire line
of of life right so and that's the end
result we wind up with yet millions of
specialized species right and and a
bacterium's flagellum has very little
information that can help me with my leg
yes this contrast to evolution is really
interesting because they're the original
bird blog-post talked about this it said
that evolution has invented astronomical
complexity for an eternity and it's an
open-ended process in much the same way
and indeed evolution has produced human
level intelligence but what's so
fascinating is is a lot of optimization
algorithms before have converged but
this continuous process that doesn't
does make it different but in evolution
there there seems to be that the the
optimization objective is
all fixed you know in real evolution
it's not fixed but but in in this
algorithm it is fixed so there is still
a bit of a difference I mean could you
kind of contrast the the I think it's
it's nice to make the connection before
with what you said what is the
difference - classic let's say
evolutionary algorithm or or curriculum
learning is that they usually have a
goal right there is like if you imagine
there is a test set of environments that
we want this agent to perform well like
in supervised learning we have a test
tests right and you could imagine this
here like we have a test set like these
five environments you need to perform
well on them is not really said that
this couette algorithm would perform
well on those it will just it kind of
has no goal as opposed to these other
algorithms that they are trying to
achieve a certain goal with this
evolutionary method but the poet
algorithm it just it has this kind of
goal of going to the right but it keeps
inventing new environments that is that
are harder and harder and harder it
comes more about creating novel things
and this is what I find a bit if like
they evaluate this against these classic
algorithms and the environments they
tested on or the environments that they
themselves came up with are the
environments that they are able to solve
and then they show all these other
algorithms aren't able to solve those
right where I think the fair comparison
would be if there was kind of a preset
test set of hard environments where you
say okay these are to be solved yeah I
mean that it's it's it's a research
focus right I'm I come from this classic
world where you need to push the metric
and get state of the art and they come
from a world where they just want to let
this algorithm run and then they see and
they say they basically the result is
Wow look what it did yeah so I want to
make one comment about sort of this this
concept that let's say older school
let's just say simulated annealing like
doesn't have a changing environment I
want to point out like a possible
connection for for you younger smarter
folks when you go to do research on this
so let's say I got this contour map and
I'm try
to find the global minimum right and
simulated annealing you have this
temperature component which is basically
how far do I jump in the direction of
the gradient right and higher the
temperature the further I go now what's
interesting is when the temperature is
very high local structure is just not
relevant because all these higher-order
derivatives and whatnot they just end up
not mattering because I jump like
straight over them right as it starts to
cool down all that local structure and
details starts to become important and I
see that our low the what's the same
thing that's happening in poet which is
I start off with this kind of smooth
environment and it doesn't really even
have any local structure rather than I
have local structure but I'm ignoring it
and simulated annealing and it becomes
rougher and rougher that's an alga stew
as I cool down all this local structure
starts to matter so there may be kind of
like a very elegant sort of parametric
way almost to move to frame that so that
you can start to take more advantage of
all the rich information content all
right I think what you're describing is
kind of the genius behind the
compositional pattern producing Network
that's encoding these environments now
instead of the original folk favor with
the handcrafted heuristics like you know
frequency of obstacle height of the
obstacles depth of the you know ditches
in the map so I think this compositional
pattern producing Network it provides
the environment in such a space that you
can do something like simulated
annealing where you globally jump
dramatically where I think the
handcrafted feature of Everest can't do
that dramatic of a global jump and
that's what I think is so interesting
about poet to the enhanced poet and then
as you mentioned earlier going into you
know like supervised learning problems
like really not just by sandal walking
agents we're like the most dramatic
environment you can imagine would be
like an uphill and maybe like it drops
it breaks like that you know I mean
trees yeah yes I think that's that
compositional pattern producing Network
is such an interesting component of this
new paper and how you do global
structure jobs yeah I mean there's a
couple of things to talk about here as
well so the in general I like this
narrative its software started office as
handcrafted rules and increasingly human
beings are being used for less and
handcrafted you know features in the
system so even when we had deep learning
for example
yes features were learned as part of the
training process but there were so many
inductive priors hard-coded into the
architecture and even even this is
interesting so we get on to
reinforcement learning and curriculum
learning and now with with trusting the
machine to learn the curriculum so in in
general we seem to be moving along this
path where we're trusting the Machine
more and more to create the rules yeah
absolutely I think you but we see that
everywhere right so you know Gantz
they're hugely successful is
particularly for that reason is because
we don't have to kind of you know
handcraft you know the data set for them
they just figure it out unsupervised
learning semi-supervised learning I
think everything is going in this
general direction of being able to to an
extent being able to gather the proper
examples that would give it the the
correct solution I think what the poet
paper and the a sport but it does
differently though is it's basically
saying there is no way to kind of
optimize this in a nagging sense or in
every enforcement learning sense I have
to do something that's a bit more
open-ended and this open ended
exploration will allow me to arrive at
solutions that I would not be it would
not be possible for me to arrive through
other means now maybe in the future
someone will come along and say there
was a way to use this optimization
method to achieve something similar to
poet but I don't think that's the point
I think the point is you know achieving
results without being able to have like
where either the gradients or other
information would be misleading and as
you touched on a point there as well
because it I think that the ubirr blog
post said that it turns out that unknown
problems can be extremely useful
especially if there's safety related
educators you know in which one of us
driving for example yeah but yeah I mean
that this this brings me onto another
interesting point as well which is the
the concept of intelligence in general
and even an artificial general
intelligence because if you took one of
these bipedal agents and you placed them
in another completely different
environment they would be completely
useless but but it raises this
philosophical question about
intelligence because
while chalet the man the legend he has
he has something to say about this and
he wrote an interesting paper which i
think is it is on the is it called on
the measure of intelligence we're gonna
do a discussion about that soon I hope
his big thing is that he doesn't believe
that an explosion in intelligence is
even possible we shouldn't be worried
about artificial general intelligence
because intelligence is expressed as a
function it's it's a an expression of
the of the environment in which the
agent lives and this seems like a
perfect example of that well I think
it's about the product of the search
like if the poet algorithm is developing
like a neural controller mapping input
the output like this kind of a circuit
topology it's like a neural arcticus
search and that's the product of search
and then that might be able to
generalize to like the Atari suite or
some but it says to say because the
input that's so different but yeah I
think it's about the product of the
search and then again to this idea of
the Asian the environment are
necessarily couple those you mentioned
can't like separate one out yeah I think
it I think if I if I understood
correctly I think the if by the product
of the search do we mean the actual
structure of the intelligence that we
end up creating is that yeah I totally
agree with that because you know since
we're talking about evolution let's
think about the fact that I think the
number is about 25,000 there's a number
of genes that we suspect you know human
beings have right and of course it's
super hard to translate that into any
type of what's a comparable parameter
you know information complexity or
whatever I'm not sure anybody really
knows how to do that yet but the point
is that's a pretty small number at least
in a sense when you think about the
complexity of these algorithms that
we're trying to create here right like
just the numbers of parameters and like
the complexity structures so I think I
think at some point we're gonna discover
that the key to generalize ability is
simplicity ie parsimony and we have to
find some way whatever that is you know
nonlinear neural networks I don't know
of having far more parsimonious
intelligences that we're trying to
optimize
yes I mean I did a paper review cool
with Mattie the other week and that was
about the lottery ticket hypothesis and
I mean I good I think Matthew can talk
to it's much much better than me so it's
okay go ahead well that's a very good
point I wasn't actually thinking of that
but it exactly to your point is you know
if you think of how many neurons you
have in your brain you exceed you know I
there's not enough genes for you to be
able to encode them absolutely so there
definitely has to be some process that
happens mmm after the kind of agent is
created that allows for this to kind of
happen yeah and there's obviously a lot
of stuff by yes your Benji obviously
relating more to you know what's the
idea of consciousness am I to require
attention and why is our short time
memory so limited according like an
information bottleneck and having
information bottleneck seems to be
import and generally through many kind
of things that we observe in nature but
also kind of we find it to be important
in machine learning models as well you
know we always try to protect some sort
of light in space now how now the
question is is I'm not a geneticist and
so therefore being able to say you know
what genes are important and how the
process of genes and whether the
information and genes to be able to
encode intelligence is there that's a
difficult question to answer I feel and
yeah maybe maybe we are able to kind of
discover something with far fewer genes
because or far fewer pieces of
information because evolution is not an
efficient process you know if you look
take what human is like our eyes are
incorrectly wired we have like on top of
the retina you know we maybe maybe not a
lot of that is sometimes just lack of
imagination you know people figure out
later that there's actually a good
reason for structural components no no
the cephalopods oh I know I slip let's
have better eyes on us yeah but it's
better in what environment that's what
I'm saying so for example when I was a
PhD student it was there was all this
talk about junk DNA see all this junk
DNA it Sarah turns out it's not junk so
I'm just saying a lot of times were
arguing
ignorance but I think um so something to
think about and this is where you know
and maybe this is already happening and
I don't know because I'm not an expert
in this field but what I'm talking about
is let's suppose I look at neural
networks and I looked at neural networks
that were successful across a variety of
problems do people actually ever dive in
and try to look for structures that are
being created within those networks I
mean look we keep seeing these seven
nodes to keep arranging here and
actually what they're doing is computing
a second-order derivative and so maybe
we should just incorporate a layer that
computes second order derivatives like
much more efficiently does anybody put
any effort into that like really diving
in to look for common low-level
structures your search is kind of around
that and you see a lot of stuff around
both evolving I think more recently
indeed mine did an evolution of a
different type of normalization layer
but these types of things do come about
from your own architecture search so
people do but again it still depends on
the data set that you optimize towards
right I think that that point is like
with these bird models and the attention
patters in the bird models I think to
unify kind of what we're talking about
is the big problem would say taking poet
and then playing Atari with it that you
have to figure out how to map that input
domain and it was you know the angular
velocity on the hip joint of the bipedal
walking age it doesn't make any sense to
transpose just one of the images there's
some kind of input modality unifying
function that complexes hell you're
never gonna figure out that so that's
why I was like you know within natural
language processing they have the same
input domain you know these by parent
coding token edge words and all these
different tasks question answering
summarization natural language inference
you know named entity recognition blah
blah blah and then they have this bird
model and they're you know slamming bird
on you know pre-training it and finding
all these different tasks and that's
where I think they're trying to look at
this underlying what kind of attention
pattern arises in all of these tasks
like what is bird looking at in natural
language inference what's looking at
summarization then I guess that's kind
of maybe the best I think I say that's
the best area of research in like
interpretability that's out there big
vision has a similar analog is like
inspecting attention patterns Bert yeah
now that's a really good point and
Matthew what did you call that
it's called it's called neural what
structure your neural architecture
church thank you
Mass but if we're trying to maybe go
back to the question of intelligence or
something like this
the problem with mapping this and and
something like poet is exactly that if
you if you think of the ladder of where
what you said before Tim is we started
you know solving puzzles ourselves and
then we know exactly what's going on
right and then we start building
programs and then we don't know the
compiler does something weird but we
still write the code and then we you
know we do neural networks and now we
know the input/output but we don't know
what happens in between and with ganz we
don't know what you're coming out we
just know it looks good right and so
we're giving away more and more freedom
of the out over the output by acquiring
more and more power and now with poet
I'm like I'm skeptical it whether or not
it's going to create intelligence all we
can say it's like let's say this is the
most powerful algorithm if we have the
compute all we can say is that is going
to create something very interesting
right exactly the the the the statement
that this is going to be intelligence is
is very questionable unless you have
some mathematical theorem that the most
interesting thing is actually
intelligence right it's although the
most interesting things will always end
up at intelligence if that's not given
writing it will produce something like
super interesting because that's what
it's designed to do but it's not
designed to achieve a goal right yes a
mathematical definition of intelligence
as interesting well maybe right maybe
that maybe there's like an argument to
be made that whatever if you find the
most interesting thing in any direction
it is always going to be intelligent
like the computer vision people they
have the point at infinity right where
all the lines cross and rhythm won't
won't end up at
at the goal that you would like it to
end up at no it's probably no no
definitely not but I think that's the
that's the point I think that they're
making is that there is it's just
open-ended it just explores and
hopefully really real something
interesting I think something that's
remarkable about the open-endedness is
that it still produces like officiously
complex terrain at the end and I think
the whole sewing point of the paper is
what we produced it's rain and you
cannot use Everest I strategies of PPOs
it something that can do this otherwise
yeah I think like to relate it back to
the generative adversarial Network idea
it's like would the agent be the
generator and the environment be
discriminator or what the agent be the
generator discriminator couples and the
environment is the data set that they're
using underneath and so we think about
like that data set becoming a complex
terrain even though it's so high
dimensional but running that experiment
would probably be impossible you could
imagine that it comes up with some data
said that it produces some image video
audio you know whatever domain is
interesting to you like say a video you
know say it writes a movie and that's
the complex terrain it comes out of that
yeah yeah yeah well I think also to your
point though is that you know once
you've ran poet to get to some point
okay you can then say okay this agent
what path did it take and that
curriculum that it took becomes
deterministic because then you go okay
this is what I'm gonna do better train
it from here to here and I think that's
that's also another important concept is
that the information of each training
step throughout this kind of hierarchy
isn't lost because the agent is the you
know transferring this information on
because it doesn't start from zero it is
kind of kept its training from the
previous rounds and so I think it's a
way of discovering a novel pathway so
correct me if I'm wrong but I thought to
result at any point at any step of this
algorithm is it's a population of agents
right they perform best and some subset
of the other domain so I'm just curious
from a practical perspective suppose I'm
trying to use you know poet to train
whatever an algorithm to do by petal
motion in a general environment and I
run my algorithm for a while and I use
Azure and have tons of compute and at
the end I've got five agents what do I
do now
like which one you know which one should
I deploy to my robot I guess is my
question and or should is there some way
to combine those well here would be my
guess I'd say with your real-world robot
you'd want to get like a world model
such that you can take this thing into
simulation and then it would be just
like open a eyes automatic domain
randomization for how they solve Rubik's
Cube how you it this same curriculum is
exactly how they manipulate the Rubik's
Cube so I think and I also think that it
seems like ADR solves sim to real
transfer a little bit you know all right
like yeah this is to Yannick sort of
point earlier is that you at the end you
have to have sort of the golden
environment that you that you're testing
yes right yes well and I would believe
that you you create so there's there's
this trade-off between how many
interesting things you get right and
your goal and maybe maybe one can create
an algorithm where you you can imagine
you first run poet all exploration mode
right and then at a certain time you put
more and more selective pressure on the
environment not the agent but the
environment to conform more and more
towards the environment that you want to
perform well branching and then kind of
converging on that environment so over
time you would like have you put on the
pressure for the environment to go there
right there so this I can imagine
something like this might work if you
actually had a goal in mind right of
course another sorry another hyper
parameter to tune more when we already
have a million you know sure so another
interesting observation I had again I
was speaking with Matthew and his
colleague Ilya karmanov recently and we
were getting into the various different
types of symmetries and different
manifolds and different inductive priors
that have been encoded into neural
network architectures and I guess what
was kind of jumping out to me was that
the complete lack of those things in
this architecture so there must be
some obvious symmetries in these
environments so for example what happens
if you if you mirrored the the mountain
structure or what happened if you did
some rotations or so on and it would be
possible to create inductive priors to
capture these and not only that because
of the way it's using some kind of a
population based optimization system
time in some sense in some sense is
being collapsed because there are
planning variants of reinforcement
learning that you know that maze solving
is the canonical example so this doesn't
really even appear to be learning from
delayed rewards in a direct sense it's
almost like a side effect of this
population optimization so I guess the
question is on the one hand it seems
like inductive priors are a good thing
but is that antithetical to
open-endedness well there's still a lot
of inductive priors that go into the
cgpm environment including like if you
don't put it if you don't wrap it in
like a sine or cosine function it'll
like imagine like x squared at the
environment being the final life it's
just cool you know that's where I think
inductive priors actually do still like
it's not like no priors algorithm I
don't think there's always priors
whether you whether you make them
explicit or not they're there try that
but I think um the reason why you don't
necessarily need to have priors and this
is because the problem domain isn't huge
enough to require you to restrict it
like priors are in essence restricting
and whether this is you're making it
something so you said you know the
equivalence you know when you're making
these various assumptions about how
everything is you're basically saying
okay model don't care about this whereas
in the open end notice you're like okay
I don't want to I want to minimize as
much as possible because I don't want to
bias my model I'll just let it explore
so they are slightly antithetical but
they can be used to kind of improve
matters in situations where it's
intractable it's a huge prior in this
kind of work I believe is is smoothness
in various forms for example in the in
the environment encoding you're relying
on the fact that if I change my seed
value of the environment a little bit
that
the environment itself will only change
a little bit otherwise you have almost
no chance right yeah you want to you
want to say if I do a small mutation
probably I'm gonna get a small change in
the environment that's my agent can
still solve right so yeah and likewise
on the agent side if you do this
evolutionary step optimization you know
you also want to say if I change my
parameters a little bit then it's going
to act somewhat differently so I believe
this this smoothness it's in code in
this environment and also on the agent
side is probably the biggest prior that
that you you have an S which makes sense
right but yes still absolutely that is
yeah I guess I guess the key there is is
and this is pointed out is that uh you
know like Connor said since we're
constructing the environment were in a
way alleviating the need for so many
inductive priors I mean we're still
Houston poet to an Aires poet unless
priors in the environment which it which
i think is really interesting because
you know like maybe it's kind of like
something that I'm curious about like if
anyone has a little bit of better
understanding of these PPN networks is
like how much does it really differ to
use a CP pn to encode the environment
compared to having like another friend
rise neural network so you know like a
neural network that just maps from X to
Y is it like they seem really similar to
me I don't really see the difference
yeah I haven't read the cppm paper
because again I think that's kind of
Stanley's paper on CP PN I would assume
it would be similar but then that's just
a guess I think your your assumption is
correct yeah I mean it seems like
they're just they insert functions and
they insert weight to the functions I
guess maybe like having the functions or
I think maybe the CPM the intermediate
functions are a little easier to
discover and say like constructing sign
by wrapping it through like two hidden
own layers and something like that maybe
yeah maybe you're right
this is yeah exactly sure but they have
another paper that I think is really
interesting when you're thinking about
how do you go from poet and bipedal
walking agents do something like image
classification
supervised learning which is have paid
for generative teaching networks which
is where they're creating a data set and
this data set is like it looks like
nonsense but apparently you train on
that data set for like 10 steps and you
can get like 90% is going to test that
like where no matter how fully fledged
that idea is there's definitely
something interesting within generative
teaching networks and then these kind of
frameworks I think yeah kana just for
the benefit of the the audience and you
give a little bit more flavor on
generative teaching networks so
generative teaching networks is like
this meta learning framework where you
have the teacher is producing a data set
so it's like it's got a generator
architecture where it goes from lazy
vector Z into high dimensional images
and it produces this whole data set that
is then evaluated on how quickly you can
train the classifier to perform well on
a held-out validation set and then once
you finish the inner loop with the
validation set you take that to the test
set and you say ok we discover this data
set you train it on it and now you got
90 percent actors going to test set but
you know hopefully not too biased with
you know obviously the data splitting
and that is in the inner loop validation
test that may be a problem but so then
the interesting thing about it also is
that the data set produced by general
teaching networks it does not look like
a mr. ceebar tenant kind of like random
noise and almost looks not quite random
but it's like the first game you've ever
trained yeah I mean it's really
interesting because one of the main
limitations of machine learning has been
access to training data and effectively
and then some of these interesting
architectural patterns that might come
out of this are really interesting any I
can't any time someone brings up images
now I can't help but think about these
adversarial image kind of kind of
attacking you know methods right that we
went over a paper one day how can I
create an image that looks like static
and makes everybody think it's not all
the algorithms think it's a hot dog you
know I want to see a test with with poet
where if we put in a particular little
shape on the ground it just always falls
down no matter no matter what you know
that would be an interesting test these
datasets
sorry and these are data sets that these
these
these teaching networks come up with
probably a very intrinsic connection to
adversarial examples because at least in
in certain researchers view of
adversarial examples they they kind of
are just low low magnitude features in
the data and that's probably exactly
what these teaching networks produce
right they just produce data that just
contains these features that are most
indicative of the of whatever class
you're yours right and and that's right
not because you as a human singing so so
maybe there's there's a very intrinsic
connection I'm pretty sure that if the
poet it will it will do the same thing
right it will have some very subtle
features that it pays attention to and
then you'll be able to just put that one
feature there and it'll just completely
go off the rails that's why I want to
see more investment into this what we
call it again the neural architecture
search right which is you know what's
the little group of nodes that's leading
to this decision you know oh it's
looking at a yellow line next to a black
line or a boundary between yellow and
black and must be a School Bus you know
that type of thing like let's look at
these little features and really dive
into them you know let's not just
completely rip humans out of the feature
set sort of engineering phase let's
let's try to work together right and see
what's going on well I think there
there's a lot of literature kind of
around this has Bayley established that
the kind of stuff that we get on
adversarial examples that we can't see
is mainly high frequency and it's
because we can't perceive it it's just
not possible for a human to perceive it
and the question then becomes is that if
you guide a machine to be like a human
to kind of see like a human your mate
you're basically trying to imbue it with
it the human logic and understanding but
it doesn't mean that because it's using
this high frequency information it's
wrong you know papers have done this
kind of investigation have found that
these features seem to generalize so why
do they generalize no one's quite sure
we can't introspect at ourselves from
our point of view because we don't use
that piece of information so I think you
might be right to kind of imbue it with
like the certain understanding of how a
human does the
but the other side of things it may put
us into a bottleneck that is kind of
like you know the way that we see the
world well I think this is infinitely
you know connected to parsimony and in
my opinion you know we've let our we've
let our machine learning run far too
amuck into the massive parameter space
with absolutely no parsimony whatsoever
and and I mean you know the universe for
all its complexity it seems to be based
on very simple laws right like like
second-order differential equations or
whatever and if we don't structure in
this simplicity in this far Simoni I
think we're gonna keep having these
kinds of problems like like the uber car
is gonna run somebody over because they
had a key chain they had a certain shape
you know we've got to get away from that
there's a couple of issues there because
I was watching a next video about the
project they're cheering you know the
huge language model for Microsoft and
and you can say when did world war to
end the never say oh you know ended in
1945 and it's gotten to the point now
where you know it might just be
memorizing particular you know passages
and in various different documents on
the internet but this parsimony think is
really interesting they're talking about
Keith because when I was talking to
Matthew about the lottery ticket
hypothesis paper it was almost saying
that the the parsimony is all you really
need the parameterization is almost
something that is required just for
optimization for stat you know for SGD
you know in order for it to become a
tractable convex optimization problem
you need to have that over
parameterization right and I would say
that the the problem that we might have
with you know people getting run over by
a self-driving car is there's a problem
with supervised learning not necessarily
a problem of of having you over
parameterised networks because the as
you said if you're able to give and get
the network to kind of figure out what
what would be is adversarial examples
then it would be able to train itself on
them and not mistake them in the real
world and this is one of the things that
we also see is that we see a lot of
people using synthetic data because you
can have perfect control of the world
and you can basically get it to kind of
simulate every kind of possible
environment and then basically train the
model on it now if you kind of took a
kind of idea from Ganz
a poet where you get the model to kind
of teach itself you know not to be
fooled by these adversarial examples
then it would kind of you know figure
this out it'd be interesting to contrast
because you know we were talking about
the adversarial examples are features
not bugs right yeah normal and neural
networks that are highly parametrized
and have lots of inductive priors are
they more or less susceptible to
adversarial attacks than this parrot
architecture that's a hard question it
depends it depends entirely on how the
how the age Indian poet is parameterised
right yes it like ultimately the agent
and poet is a very classic you can you
can make it a linear function or you can
make it a neural network ultimately each
agent has a policy function and that
policy function if it is a neural
network we can attack it with an
adversarial example almost surely right
if it is not explicitly trained to to
avoid that I'd be very surprised if not
right okay why don't we move the
conversation a little bit to some of the
the engineering mechanics of poet
because in your review video Yannick you
were talking about being surprised by
the amount of hyper parameters and yeah
and you thought that it was a little bit
fiddly you know there might be an issue
there with reproducibility and and could
you also describe the the time
complexity of the algorithm you know
would it scale what would happen if
there were more environments it does
more mean better etc well more it is
better in this case more environments
more agents would mean better unless you
kept your compute constant right as as
far as I understand it they're evolving
set of agents they remove the oldest
ones just because they they just can't
physically run them all at the same time
and if I recall correctly they have
something like 40 agents at any given
time so it's not this might be wrong but
I think
it's about the order of magnitude said
they don't have tens of thousands they
just they have a couple that they keep
around and pay for the new one joints
they drop out the old one so I in terms
of time complexity I mean you have you
in each step you need to go over every
single agent mutate it then you need to
test every other agent on that new
environment right to estimate the
transfer thing and then you need for
everyone you need to do an evolution
step which means you need to noise
perturb all of the parameters in in a
couple of ways and then check which
one's the best right so there's like
inner loop and inner loop an inner loop
in this in this our algorithm it's not
it's not exponential per se but it is it
is very consuming of resources and and
each one of these things you need to
tune right so there is a how many steps
do I take in the inner optimization then
how what's the step size there what's
learning rate what's the noise and then
after how many steps do I check the
agents where is the cutoff for it's too
easy where it's the cutoff for it's too
hard and so on this this is just extreme
extremely labor-intensive from an
engineering perspective the enhanced
poet solves some of these issues where
it introduces it introduces kind of for
example this notion of novelty it really
defines okay here is when we here is a
generic way to say something is not
which I find really cool but still there
are so many many parameters in this that
a I think it takes it takes an
engineering team to really get something
like this running and it takes a cluster
right it's not like you could run this
algorithm I hope you need I think the
first one was done at uber AI and yeah
you need to distribute it cluster two to
run this do the point run I think is the
new one takes 12 days on 750 CPUs
and as the optimized one yeah yeah well
I with all this research and all of this
area like you know alpha 0 etc the
computer is always gonna be prohibitive
and so it's yeah it's gonna be very hard
to replicate and extrapolate necessarily
yeah because I supposed to use butter to
abuse terminology it kind of similar to
data parallel so presumably that in
order to make this work they created a
distributed version of it and they did
some kind of you know they did the es
policy update after all of the
respective agents had finished possibly
in a distributed setting I don't know
whether they expanded on how they did
that well the rhythm so you can run a
lot of concurrently so I think it's time
for long and you can distribute this one
quite nicely comparing to other our
algorithm that in India call say you
sell your eggs you think like you need
to produce reserve to go on yes if you
compare again to to evolution it's in
evolution it of the more things you
produce the more compute you have
available right but in essence it is all
parallel it evolution is parallel
parallelizable in this algorithm in
exactly the same way it has no central
thing right that that that that needs to
like if you distribute your data and
then you need to collect the updates it
doesn't have that you can destroy some
final as much as you want it has been
the final step of selecting the next
population but that seems true it's even
scoring an optimization you wouldn't
even do without that as well exactly
yeah so you can you can paralyze and
then you need a synchronous
synchronization so yeah at some point
you got to get an answer I guess which
is it's what I really liked about the NX
idea of like can we find some way to
start funneling them back towards what
we're trying to solve you know yeah it
would be a very interesting way being
interesting to do that other than just
the simplistic way of let me just take
the best one mm-hmm and even
maybe then prayer after sorry sorry
because you keep it maybe there there
needs to be some heuristics as well
because in theory one agent on one
environment could take a year to run so
we're not gonna wait for it to run maybe
we have a timeout and maybe if several
agents have already come in with a
really good time we just terminate the
other agents because we're not gonna
bother waiting for their mother and it
just sort of raises some interesting
heuristics to optimize it well that's
all Barry those type of parameters yeah
next talking about it's tough thresholds
here and there and whatever right now
they're just they've got some very
coarse ones like let's chop it down to
40 I don't know anything she's 42 I
would have gone yeah to person point but
[Music]
we are halfway because it's like like
we're doing a meeting with the older
will brainstorming with new ideas and
generate new new jate a new space new
experience and new conclusion and we
evolved with that we create skills with
that but the second part is missing like
okay and like you said what I have to
what do I do with my 15 agent that was
successful we have to summarize and and
as a way to get down to lower dimension
dimensionality and all that complexity
to have some caliber not one answer but
to reduce to something usable so I think
we are halfway there there must be new
papers on how to reduce all that
generating stuff to generate they
generate the Invalides environment to
something usable more practical
sounds like a good thesis topic any any
takers on the call yeah I think the idea
that it keeps getting more complex even
though the the new transfer objective is
just to reorder the ranking of the agent
so it's interesting that like let's say
you have this complex terrain as all the
40 agents are walking on and then you
might be able to come up with some
terrain a less complex and they would
reorder the agents and then your
environment survives evolution for
watching so just that the fact that that
cycling doesn't have
which happens all the time again you
have the like catastrophic forgetting
the discriminator and you cycle and it
doesn't get better it gets worse so I
think just the fact that you know even
though I don't know in the paper if they
take their final agent on the most
complex terrain and then say I can also
do all these other trees I think that's
the one thing in the paper that is
really lacking is that you don't see
that like not only can you not optimize
this with ESO PPO directly but this
final agent can do all these things and
I don't think any paper actually
achieves something like that even though
like they're gonna open AI hide-and-seek
agents they try to then construct these
six easier tasks and it's like it's not
better at those tests it's maybe like a
little yeah yeah yeah it's a really good
point yeah yeah like about that for
example I believe the annex said that
they kind of throw away the oldest
population like simple alternative might
be well let's keep the best ones along
with the ones that are second best in
every environment or the ones that do
well across several environments like
just a better sort of sorting strategy
would be interesting I think yeah it's
this has been a topic within that
relationally algorithms in genetic
programming for quite a while and I've
seen a lot of ways in which they do that
it always becomes a problem with
computation so with the more you retain
the more computation the more expensive
and like what payoff do you get for
doing that if there was a way I think
the key to this is being able to extract
from each of the agents for each of the
environments what is important and
that's that's the key problem here
because if you were able to kind of
instead of having to take the whole age
and all the whole environment you're
able to take a sub piece and put it with
whatever else to something that you were
saying earlier then that's the part that
would be useful and that's why I like
the idea of the agent and the
environment being part of some genome
now if you split this even further and
you basically were able and you had
multiple multiple components that in
isolation would still work then you
begin to have something that becomes a
bit more powerful in the sense that you
can optimize individual components and
they still will work together but again
that's coming up with that and how to
kind of do that is super hard like the
like the may be the introduction here of
is some alpha star they have
this concept of the League training so
in an alpha star tries to solve
Starcraft and has very different agents
it has some of the agents they just
learn the game but the other agents
they're trying to explicitly come up
with strategies to exploit these right
and and that just kind of keeps those
always kind of remembering oh yes I need
to I need to you know be able to defend
against this strategy and against this
strategies they have these single
exploiters that that always try to
attack them so if these ever forget
then it's catastrophic for them right so
that again keeps them it keeps them on
their feet and there there should be
like an ocean like this could come into
this poet framework where you basically
you're not saying like okay I'll forget
about you agent but it's I'll keep you
around you can teach the other ones what
you know yeah of course it's very hard
to implement something like that's like
the notion from these you know the the
the rock-paper-scissors AI competition
that used to be around I think it's no
longer a thing but people would create
programs to play rock-paper-scissors now
rock-paper-scissors a pretty boring game
if everybody plays the optimal
randomized solution right but if you see
the field with exploitable agents now
you have a much more interesting problem
because now you're trying to come up
with an algorithm that wins more from
the exploitable guys without losing too
much to to the you know I just gonna
choose one third rock-paper-scissors
right and so like you're saying when you
have a field that has different types of
agents exploitable ones or ones to go
after particular strategies it's a much
more you know complex terrain by the way
that's also how you solve the problem in
games of of these of these kind of
collapses is there's actually work by my
colleague from my lab that where you
kind of remember the old the old games
that you have around and you always use
them to kind of influence the newest
ones and then you can you can mitigate
this exactly the same basically as poet
does you remember the population yeah I
don't think catastrophic forgetting is
happening in poet too much just on that
same read
behind if the ranking order was shifting
dramatically and I think it was cycle
and I don't think it yeah I don't know
if it has a history like some kind of
memory of the previous trains that like
you know like having like a replay
buffer for Ganzer yeah I don't know but
you do something like that but yeah I
don't think it's just the fact that it
doesn't constantly shift the rank order
or and then you know bus get simpler I
think says that it's not catastrophic
for getting from but I definitely think
the paper needs that discussion of like
here's what happens when we take it and
put it on the easier environment
compared to the other ones or something
like that I guess yeah well in essence
you're basically asking for some sort
generalization right you know yeah you
kind of get you kind of optimized to
this kind of really difficult situation
but is is it just another way of
optimizing to a final solution which is
that final environment which we have no
idea of or is it that's a generalizable
solution yeah okay oh sorry going Connor
why well another thing no no yeah I was
gonna say that it's interesting to think
about like connecting poet with like
self supervised learning and then
thinking is generally about this agent
environment relationship like just think
about how general this planet or
evolution idea can be like we saw the
generative teaching Network idea where
you can generate data said you can also
like some supervised learning you could
the environment could be what
constructing artificial labels from the
data
I'm just curious I'm like what you're
missing like what all your thoughts are
and how you would take some framework
like this and then put it into a more
understood problem like supervised
learning performance like how would you
use poet you get better imagenet
classification yeah they can eat oats on
that yeah no problem we started with
right you you have this more and more
powerful algorithms but you're giving
away more and more the power to choose
what comes out of them and here you you
somehow have to
reintroduce this power that you say I
want a good image net classifier right
this is my goal and it is a direct in
direct conflict with what this algorithm
is good at and if if you could combine
that I I believe that there's definitely
a way and I believe that this could be
this branching and then funneling
together by after a while putting a
selective pressure on the goal that you
want I don't know any other performance
at the moment because there is something
to be said for I mean for example
there's lots of unsupervised learning
algorithms for I mean we all know about
the the famous self supervised
Transformers models in an LP Eva there
are similar things in computer vision as
well like there's the deep info max
paper you know by Devon Elm and you know
that that's a similar kind of self
supervision and that can learn really
really powerful representations that are
in some ways even better than ones
created from supervised classifiers
because they essentially haven't been
supervised it does make me think that
would a similar thing be possible if you
had a computer vision version version of
poet and you let it self play and Cohen
and co-evolved with a with a with a
curriculum would it learn some kind of
powerful internal representations that
then could be taken out of that context
and to help us in an in an entirely
different predictive architecture the
question of oh go ahead
say bye back to the idea of like
information loss within the population
like one cool idea would be like to
ensemble the population so let's say you
want to come up with the most complex
terrain that no agent could ever walk on
what you would do I think like upend be
terrains to each other and then switch
the controller's at each next rate and
then you'd be walking across this crazy
train just switching the controller so
like maybe something with imagenet
classification they each have a subset
of the data that is different enough
from each other that you combine this
ensemble and then it's like god imagenet
yeah and that's very I would say to the
point of like the image net in poet I
would say the problem there is that you
you would allow it to explore the domain
but you've got to find
model that is the this you know super
imagenet model how how did you find that
yeah you've explored this huge space but
how did you know you know you can get
better at like you can tell it you know
to make harder and harder task so like
like transformations on the images and
he kind of becomes better at doing that
but you are still guided to a final
point there is no way to say that it
this is a generalizable solution and I
think that's the open question I have an
idea yeah for Twitter a little bit
further as most getters get max retweets
sounds sounds like some sort of viruses
gonna kind of decimate social network
[Laughter]
lamp socially engineered Twitter worm
Twitter poetic exactly well it's kind of
like the meme theory from
what's-his-name
so in essence you want a meme to
propagate so in order for it perfect day
it has to kind of improve itself and so
they're doing this kind of evolution
eventually you'll end up with this super
meme so you're super Twitter post you
can probably train it with reinforcement
learning like in the fine tuning with
language models and then just reward a
three Creek idea anyway from Twitter for
doing that not a verbal circle which
account you do that from anywhere folks
we've been talking for about an hour and
ten minutes I think it's been a
fantastic conversation it's gone really
really well actually I'm really really
chuffed with it so I guess we better
close it down now so we don't want to
bore our listeners but we will be back
next week and we are planning to explore
loads and loads of different types of
content it doesn't just have to be paper
conversations we can talk about
interesting articles or you know any
controversy that's going on in the in
the Twitterverse at the moment you know
it's just an opportunity for us to have
a conversation so thanks everyone for
tuning in and we'll see you next week
thank you thank you thank you everyone
see ya likes you